these are photos of an island in the  South Pacific the place where myth and  science meet we use explosives to shake  the earth helping us to map the surface  of the island you're dropping bombs  scientific instruments  is it a monkey  magnificent  you knew that thing was out here I'm  sorry for your man car but if you want  to make this sacrifice worthwhile get us  home  with proof monsters exist  whoa your friend there can put that down  what the hell is this place  that's calm he's King around here comes  pretty good King  keeps himself mostly well you don't go  into someone's house and start dropping  bombs unless you're picking a fight  Cohen's God on the island but the Devils  live below us and what are they called  I call them skull roars why never said  that name out loud before it sounds  stupid now that I say just you call them  whatever you want  it's a good group of boys we're all  gonna die together out here haha he  should be coming here  you